in this lesson we're going to talk about
averages and mean so basically the mean
is just another name for the average and
this is an important concept to
understand for the sa ki the new revised
s80 so let's get right into it the first
thing you want to know is this basic
formula for the average which is the
total divided by how many of the items
that you're averaging right so the
averages you know that you count
everything up / you know the total
number and that's your average right so
let's see if we can get into a couple
examples see if you can pause the video
and do these on your own and we'll go
through them together if your average
for the first four test is an 85 right
what do you need to get on the fifth
test to bring your average up to an 87
so this is a common scenario where
students are you know always wondering
like what do I need to get on that the
next test so i can get you know an ad-
or a B+ or whatever it might be right so
pause the video see if you can do this
one on your own will go through it
together basically see when you're
finding an average you're taking the
total number of points right so here's
your total / in this case the first four
test gives you an average of 85 so
that's really told us the average on the
first four tests is 85 so what we can do
is you know they're always going to you
know give you like maybe you know one of
these is going to be missing you're
going to give you two out of the three
quantities you can solve for that third
quantity all you have to do is you know
multiply both sides by 4 so the total so
far your total number of points scored
is going to be how much well that's
going to be let's see 340 points right
okay but then we want to know what do
you need to get on that fifth test to
bring your average up to an 87 okay so
we're going to use our average again you
want to get an average of 87 the total
number of points we know is 340 plus
whatever we're going to score on that
fifth test divided by the number of
tests which is now up to five right what
do we need ok well let's multiply both
sides by 5 okay and you see let's see
that's 435 right equals 3 40 plus X we
subtract 3 40 from both sides of the
equation right to get X by itself and
what do we get here well let's see it
looks like it's 95 so if you get a 95 on
that fifth
that's going to bring your average up to
an 87 which is what you were shooting
for so again you want to definitely
memorize this formula if you don't know
what already substituting what you know
and saw what you know what you don't
know but see what sometimes makes these
problems difficult is there like
multiple steps you might have to do one
step then another step right okay so
let's look at example number too so you
can do this one on your own it says what
is the mean weight of a pumpkin so
remember meanings average right okay so
look at this chart so basically what it
is they're giving us a frequency this is
a histogram by the way and they're
giving us the weight of the pumpkin so
for example like over here we have one
pumpkin right there weighs one pound
over here let's see these are for palm
pumpkins we had five of those right over
here we have you know here's a five
pound pumpkin so the heavier right but
we only had two of those so we're
wondering you know what's the average
weight of a pumpkin now go ahead and
pause the video so you can do this one
on your own and we'll go through it
together but here's the thing like some
students mole mistakenly just say well 1
2 3 4 5 a 3 is in the middle that's my
average of pumpkin you know average
weight it's three pounds right but this
is more of what they call like a
weighted average and what I mean by that
is you know you're having more pumpkins
that are at the four-pound weight and
then you are at the one pound weight so
you have to wait it right the other way
to do it is you can write these all out
you could say well I've got one pumpkin
it weighs one pound I've got let's see
three pumpkins away two pounds but it's
2 2 and 2 i've got one pumpkin that
weighs three pounds I've got 25 pumpkins
at weigh four pounds right okay and then
I've got three pumpkins away five pounds
so one two three now if i add all these
um / how many i have that's going to be
my average weight for the pumpkin right
but the way to whatever way to do it
would just be the like say i've got one
at one pound I've got three at two
pounds I've got let's see you a one at
three pounds ok this would give you the
exact same result i'm just doing it in a
little bit more efficient you know
manner right three at five pounds ok so
let's see if we add this up we get 1
plus 6 plus 3 plus 20 plus 15 that's 35
plus 10 is 45
okay / how many do we have well we can
see we've got one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen right so it's 45 / 13 let's
make sure I got that right one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve fifteen so 45 / 13 so what
would that come out too well it's 13
goes into 45 let's see three times
that's 39 with six left over so it's 3 &
6 13 so that would be the best answer
apparently it's none of you that must
have made a mistake when I was putting
together this problem but essentially
what it is is it's a weighted average an
average you're taking the total divided
by how many you have and that's your
average so again review this form that
if you need to go ahead and take a look
at these examples again if you need to
and i'll see you in the next lesson